[Music]
this male arctic fox has spent the last
months
[Music]
alone he really goes the
distance when food is in short
supply one even clocked more than a,
miles in just over 2
months this little guy has been
surviving off his street
[Music]
smarts you can't be too careful when
you're only 12 in
[Music]
tall in the Arctic
even leftovers are a reason to
[Music]
celebrate with spring in the air he's
heading home to
reunite with his lifelong
[Music]
mate
they've spent The Long Winter
apart searching for
[Music]
food he must find her if there's any
hope of starting a
[Music]
family Maybe she hasn't survived the
winter ah there she
is together
again
[Music]
time to get on with the business of
becoming a mom and
dad and to raise their litter of pups
before the end of
[Music]
summer